alors soyez là où la bienvenue à tam tam
canada aujourd'hui avec de la visite
spéciale un invité mystère vous allez
découvrir qu'il est tout le monde ici un
studio c'est qu'il est donc on peut pas
jouer aux jardinières manquons fait vous
poser des questions il répond par oui ou
par non ça dure 30 minutes après ça on
retourne à la maison pas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le thème ne touchent tous
touchent les médias non seulement radio
canada on va examiner le succès et les
moins bons succès de radio canada par
rapport à cette réalité de la présence
des visages qui représentent la
diversité canadienne que ce soit à la
radio que ce soit à la télévision ou
encore sur le web sur facebook live sur
youtube sur le site de rci net
présentement nous sommes diffusés sur
trois plates formes en direct de façon
simultanée et on dit que youtube à une
seconde avance sur facebook
félicitations et youtube alors
aujourd'hui le thème que j'ai donné je
donne toujours un titre amusant à mes
émissions aujourd'hui j'ai eu toute
façon parce que attention moi quand je
peux pas vraiment et d'histoire les
visages de notre diversité dans les
médias canadiens c2c de l'émission mais
puisque vous avez d'imagination des fois
beaucoup plus que moi je vous demandais
trouvez moi un meilleur titre pour cette
émission qui parle de diversité des
visages une trentaine et à la radio on
va commencer par notre invité mystère
allait dans le même sens stephen de les
masques de la diversité parce qu'on a
tendance à les cacher beaucoup
enfin c'est joli ça j'adore ça paloma
vous pouvez faire mieux
radio canada vous ré pressante bien a
bon est ce que vous vous retrouvez en
questions
ben oui c'est bien marie-claude sommes
nous tous dans l'immédiat sommes nous
tous et puis leonardo l'histoire c'est
les accents alors je sais pas quelle est
notre note ici à l'émission côté
diversité méchant que ça va quand même
assez bien merci
un petit peu de sang indien j'avais des
origines non moi comme je dis fais des
ancêtres venus en nouvelle-france ya 375
smart on accueille luc sonor rade qui
est spécialiste de la question qu'est-ce
qui parce que c'est son adresse courriel
qui apparaît l auc six malades
oui tout à fait je devais me distinguer
d'un automne avec séance est venue de la
nouvelle taxe il ya ne puis jacques moi
c'est stéphane 42 ou faire je suis ici
avant fin août et alors c'est luc simard
vous êtes responsable des politiques de
diversité à l'antenne de radio-canada ça
occupe une bonne partie de votre journée
oui et je moi j'avais un autre site à
proposer ces démissions ya pas encore de
marc de petit homme blanc à l'antenne
tout en vert à l'antenne
il ya des hommes blancs comme moi mais
il n'y a pas d'eau mais on n'est pas
encore avec des martiens mais on fait du
progrès par rapport la diversité mais ce
qu'on pourrait dire les choses
quantifier les choses parce qu'on a des
gens à l'étranger qui se disent mais
pourquoi il parle de diversité à
l'antenne
chez nous il n'y a pas de problème et au
canada il ya il ya une grande présence
de gens qui sont nés à l'étranger à
montréal au canada toronto enfin on
pourra faire le tour mais quelle quelles
sont les statistiques que vous pourriez
sortir de votre boîte à outils qui nous
ferait voir là l'importance du défi qui
nous attend
alors vous savez puis le ch et même pas
regardé les derniers
en fait oui ce sont les derniers
chiffres et les airs et des chefs du
dernier recensement 2016 et on voit que
les minorités visibles
on prend l'ensemble du canada ces 22 3%
de la population
donc disons à peu près un quart de la
population et quand on regarde montréal
c'est à peu près la même proportion
donc évidemment la ville de montréal est
à l'image du canada dans son ensemble et
on a donc ici beaucoup de
deux jeunes de minorités visibles si on
regarde également l'immigration c'est
qu'il ya énormément donc de d'immigrants
canada c'est c'est un pays d'émigration
donc en ce moment je n'ai je n'ai pas
exactement les chiffres pour montréal
mais on est peut-être que paloma ici qui
naviguent dans ces eaux là encore mais
on sait qu'à montréal
ce qu'on sait qu'à montréal une personne
sur deux a au moins un parent né à
l'étranger
donc ça fait cinquante pour cent de la
population montréalaise qui appartient
soit minorités visibles une unité
audible ou encore donc 50%
beaucoup dont qui ont des références
culturelles puis si je reviens aux
minorités visibles
évidemment on peut de minorités visibles
à montréal des êtres de huitième
génération donc il n'y a pas de lien
direct entre le fait d'être issus des
migrations est une minorité visé faut
toujours distinguer des deux c'est très
important qu'ils sont en forme et encore
quand on est droit mais que lens était
venu ici à la fin du xviiie au début du
19e siècle
ça commence à faire vraiment moi t'es
pas l'oms est là non seulement parce que
c'est une équipe une équipe pas membre
de l'équipe régulière
voilà vous êtes unique c'est vrai elle
fait beaucoup de choses quand vous
faites quelque chose dans la journée on
le sait vous êtes passé par là mais
sérieusement on fait partie aussi de
l'équipe de luc simard oui je travaille
pas twitter mais très souvent avec luc
simard autant dans la question de la
recherche pour enrichir notre répertoire
de diversité à radio canada parce qu'on
a un répertoire dans lesquels duquel les
journalistes peuvent se servir pour
aller chercher des gens des sources
d'information diversifiée donc je
travaille un peu pour ça mais je fais
aussi des fruits donnent aussi des
formations à des journalistes à la
recherche à radio canada et puis on
rencontre assez souvent des personnes
des journalistes de sani matin des
rédacteurs en chef pour leur parler un
peu des objectifs qu'à radio-canada cdn
concernant la diversité culturelle des
minorités à radio-canada faut expliquer
ici encore une fois ceux qui sont à
l'étranger connaissent pas bien
radio-canada ou ici bicic la diversité
canadienne
il faut la représenter à radio-canada ça
fait partie du mandat de cette société
d'état s'est aussi ont fait pas ça on va
faire parler
il ya de l'argent qui suit avec ça
normalement si on remplit pas les
objectifs pour lesquels on a été on été
mise au monde mais je dirais aux délais
de stéphane ceux qui on s'adresse à un
public diversifié on dit c'est lorsque
la société canadienne diversifiée
donc les gens s'attendent le public
s'attend à ce qu'on représente leur
réalité donc la réalité dans laquelle
les canadiens vivent est une réalité
diversifié dans laquelle elle est expert
des tout dans toutes sortes de domaines
et des experts de toutes origines
confondues
donc ils s'attendent à ça de nous donc
de nous le travailleur les créateurs
alors vous savez que cette émission est
construite
un peu comme rome au dessus de cette
colline a des yeux sans appeler ça des
vidéos ici en langage web
alors nous allons vous présenter cette
première vidéo bon allez voir ce qui se
passe ailleurs un de critiquer
radio-canada en vacances qui les autres
bien normal alors voici vidéo
75ème anniversaire de montréal l'an
dernier vidéo virale
[Musique]
je passe au toute ma vie c'est chez nous
ces nouvelles pages en l'air
[Musique]
grosso à 15 heures
bonne foi
alors ils ont inscrits hurel de montréal
mais pas le visage multiculturel de
montréal ça fait beaucoup de bruit cette
histoire notamment dans les réseaux
sociaux quesque pourquoi est ce qu a eue
ce dérapage est ce qu on le sait il n'ya
aucune personne des minorités visibles
un moyen sur cinq est absent je passe
entre les enfants à la fin il y en avait
mais regardez ça fait c'est ce qui m'a
surpris les plus je comprends que les
visages de bouc culturel comme vous
dites du de montréal et peut-être blanc
est décédé j'ai une française et
anglaise
mais les les enfants de montréal c'est
pas ça donc à la fin on voit un certain
nombre d'enfants
je me suis posé la question comment ils
sont faits à quelle école ils sont allés
pour aller chercher ces groupes
il n'y a pas de diversité c'est très
difficile de versailles ont dû
travailler voire vous trouvez ces jeunes
à la défense des organisateurs du 375e
en fait ils ont offert une version après
ça parce qu'ils ont été âprement qu'il
essaie même montréalais sur quatre qui
2001 était visible donc ça n'avait tout
simplement pas de bon sens c'est bien ce
qu'ils ont tellement bien travaillé
qu'ils ont effacé toute trace de cette
vidéo il n'existe qu'un seul endroit à
un radio canada international
marie-claude vous comprenez c'est ce
visage très culturelle mais sens en
multi mais c'est finalement ce n'est pas
représentatif c'est un manque de
sensibilité 16h voit que ce n'était pas
une priorité c'était pas un objectif
qu'ils avaient en faisant la vidéo elle
avait pas encore de s'organiser parce
que je crois que c'est une réalité
on les voit ici à radio-canada aussi on
a nos réseaux de contacts nos réseaux
professionnels nous ressemblent souvent
et puis à radio canada je n'ai pas les
chiffres au niveau de s'employer à
radio-canada mai
call of duty ces chiffres là mais c'est
ce que je sais c'est que les réseaux
radio canadien où les réseaux des médias
québécois en général c'est des réseaux
je n'aime pas le dire le terme sur son
bilan le reste soit francophone mais
j'ai l'impression quand même cas que ce
qui manque de diversité par tout ça des
récents ils savent on peut aller à
l'école primaire chez les saint jean des
raisons pour lesquelles ses rangs doute
pas à ces milieux là mais je crois que
il ya tout ça les résaux sons sont très
homogènes ce phénomène de société je
pense que tu as tout à fait raison c'est
un c'est importé en fait ce qu'on vient
de voir si le portrait de l'industrie
culturelle québécoise qui n'est pas de
la société et dans l'industrie
québécoise de la culture et j'inclus les
médias et j'ai inclus même radio canada
là dedans parce que dans le fond tout ce
qu'on fait ce sont des produits
culturels et je mets même l'information
dans les produits culturels
mais ils sont s'élargit pour regarder le
théâtre quand on regarde l'ensemble de
la télévision les variétés les
dramatiques on voit jusqu'où cinéma et
on prend même la musique
les arts visuels etc c'est ça c'est
beaucoup ça et beaucoup de gens qui
aimeraient entrer dans cette industrie
mais qui font face à toutes sortes
d'obstacles dit c'est ça c'est comme ça
voyons comment c'est un radio canada
maintenant donc grande révélation
ça va faire sourciller beaucoup des gens
à beaucoup de gens voici vous allez nous
expliquer on peut occasion pour pas
rater les chiffres voici ce que les
internautes voient en ce moment vous
leur décrivez cette première page de
série de données que vous avez colligées
oui alors c'est intéressant il serait au
canada on a un super système d'archivage
de nos émissions qui nous permet de
savoir exactement ce qu'on met à
l'antenne
y compris donc le genre d'éviter que
nous invitons dans nos émissions donc
ici on parle des émissions de télé on
part des émissions d'information on peut
revenir juste en arrière un petit peu
alors donc les émissions et ici on voit
la radio donc les chiffres se
ressemblent c'est environ 3% de
minorités visibles
un peu plus à la télé 3,5 et un peu
moins à la radio donc c'est évidemment
toujours plaisir d'identifier les
minorités visibles à la radio mais sinon
mais vous voyez est donc si on regarde
ça tout à l'heure on disait à peu près
un quart donc 23% plus précis minorités
visibles à montréal et dans nos
émissions de radio ou de télé grosso
modo à peu près 3% donc on voit bien
qu'on est on n'est pas au niveau qu'on
devrait être il ya toujours des raisons
évidemment qui peuvent expliquer ça
c'est la populaire c'est quoi le niveau
qui on devait quand tu devrais être même
idéalement devrait être au niveau de la
population on devrait avoir à notre
antenne sauvette le vrai reflet de la
société montréalaise si je pense juste
la société montréalaise et donc je
m'excuse pour tous les gens qui nous
écoutent et j'imagine que c'est
l'immense majorité qui sont en dehors de
montréal mais faut il faut savoir tout
simplement je pense que tout le monde tu
nous écoutes le sait que l'immense
majorité dans les émissions nos
entrevues sont faites ici à partir de
montréal par jour sur des sujets
montréalais mais des invités sauve ici
donc c'est pour ça que c'est important
donc d'être capable de nous hisser à un
niveau qui ressemble à celui de la
population va ajouter un peu de vision
canadienne
on va sortir de montréal un petit peu du
québec on va parler de chiffres vous
avez déjà eu quelques doses
d'informations qui vous permettrait
d'avoir la réponse à cette première
question de la journée deux premiers
volets ménage donc c'est le premier jeu
de la journée je rappelle que ce premier
jeu il y en a trois dans l'émission ce
premier jeu vaut pour 20% du score final
libre avant toutes les réponses or voici
sur 36 millions de canadiens en 2016
combien de millions étaient nés à
l'étranger
et combien de millions elle était venue
minorités visibles les deux chaises sont
partis peu après pratiquement comparable
voulait pas déjà répondu à l'auditorio
nardo hockey les 5 millions 5 millions 7
millions 7 millions je sais pas vion
l'humiliant 7 millions je suis vraiment
dans la bonne zone comme on dit je
voulais vous parler un petit peu ici de
2,2 toujours du projet de radio canada
d'améliorer le score parce que c'est
l'idéal or on sait que ça va pas très
bien
bon qu'est ce qu'on fait alors là on
sait je vous amis non seulement vous
voulez changer des choses à l'intérieur
de radio canada par bon le dialogue
les réunions en disant monsieur est venu
en donnant des outils
on en a parlé un peu plus tôt mais aussi
on essaie de convaincre par exemple mais
en disant si vous voulez faire affaire
avec radio canada peut-être que vous
aussi vous devriez songer sérieusement
dans l'industrie 1 avoir cette notion de
justice par rapport à la salle
culturelle de notre société
il ya un projet particulier en ce moment
même plus qu'un projet donc
une obligation qui est maintenant faite
depuis le mois de décembre donc c'est
tout récent depuis le mois dernier à
tous les producteurs indépendants qui
veulent présenter des émissions radio
canada alors c'est important de
distinguer ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
à la télé c'était des émissions
d'information c'est la leçon faite
entièrement à long terme de résultats de
la part du personnel de radio canada dit
luc on va ajouter une vidéo pour appuyer
vos propos vous la regardez et vous
allez voir vous êtes dans votre monde
vous allez lui écrire ce qui se passe
c'est quelque chose que les gens à
l'extérieur pourront voir les gens qui
veulent faire affaire avec nous vous
reconnaissez donc oui je te fais alors
comment souhaite un projet alors ça ça
vaut donc pour tous les gens qui veulent
s'y mettent un projet d'émission de
variétés un projet de documentaire ou en
projet de série dramatique à radio
canada donc on passe rapidement ici mais
tu es très facile à trouver sur le site
internet de radio canada
et vous voyez on vient de voir deux
types de documents qui sont attachées
alors ces documents là c'est simplement
d'abord un document qui explique
pourquoi on veut faire ça et
essentiellement ça nous rappelle
l'importance de refléter la population
et l'autre document baisser ce
formulaire là que vous voyez en ce
moment c'est à dire un plan d'inclusion
de la diversité qui oblige dorénavant
les producteurs indépendants et
n'oublions pas encore une fois l'immense
majorité des émissions que les gens qui
nous écoutent voit la télévision les
émissions de variétés les séries de
remercier c'est l'immense majorité de
vision et toutes ces émissions là sont
faites par des porteurs indépendant donc
depuis décembre le producteur
indépendant doit présenter un plan
d'inclusion de la diversité qui définit
ce qu'il veut mettre à des cas donc quel
type de contenu que bon un
jeu-questionnaire dijon sur quel sujet
les sujets de stéphane ou d'autres types
de sujets qui va animer est ce que ce
sera oui animateurs jouent ils ont été
visés dans le queyras pas trop visible
dans ce cadre
est-ce que la thématique va toucher
sujet de diversité culturelle qu'est
l'auditoire on va te sûr évidemment
chaque émission vingtaine de l'histoire
maximale est ce que dans les rôles
principaux sont talent de série
dramatique par exemple excuse des rôles
principaux vont être donnés à des
comédiennes et comédiens de minorités
visibles ce que l'animateur du jeu
questionnaire sur un animateur deux
minorités quelconque et les autres
personnalités vous inviter à l'antenne
alors tout ça va être inclus dorénavant
les déjà en fête est déjà une obligation
que les producteurs et ça a l'air de
rien mais c'est un immense pas en avant
pour radio canada parce qu'auparavant on
avait trois lignes qui disait fait les
meilleurs efforts possibles pour
refléter la diversité de la population
dorénavant il ya un beau formulaire sais
pas trop compliqué mais il faut se
creuser les méninges et trouver quelque
chose je sais que votre approche c'est
la carotte met pas de bâtons
je suis pas mal de sites incontournables
maintenant qu'elle se dit plus possible
de présenter un projet d'émission même
pour les détecteurs devant lui mais est
ce que vous allez revenir après en
disant observer zemeckis ans en 2018 non
c'est pas vrai vous avez pas vous
répondre
la promesse est ce que vous allez faire
ça ça va t'on ce sont mes collègues
évidemment des tensions responsable des
variétés de la masia qui doivent
appliquer ça donc
et je leur fais entièrement confiance
pour répliquer ça je pense qu'on va voir
des entrées métier qui s'apprend trois
ans développé une série qu'on pourra
voir à l'antenne on verra pas le
résultat de mes matins on variété ça va
un peu plus vite mais ça va quand même
ça prend un certain temps développer des
concepts et et tourner des épisodes on
va le voir je suis persuadé qu'on va le
voir
et comment mesurer ça je sais pas si
vous avez envie que je vous parle je
sors de radio canada
je sors de radio canada parce que les
producteurs indépendants avec qui on
fait affaire producteur d'émissions
trimestre ces coûts d'émission de
variétés
ce sont souvent les mêmes producteurs
avec lesquels avec lesquelles vivent
avec lesquels les chaînes spécialisées
de bellefon à faire alors on a une
approche qui se situe au niveau de
l'industrie
alors moi ce que je veux
est ce que je cherche on a un groupe de
travail qu'on a formé il ya déjà plus de
trois ans c'est d'arriver à des critères
d'industrie c'est que toute l'industrie
progressent poche radio-canada ça que
nous on est on sait si les autres il
faut à peu près la même chose ou quelque
chose du genre
alors on est entré d'aller dans cette
direction là parce que on est en train
de concevoir en ce moment avec une
université l'école des hautes études
commerciales de montréal hec montréal
comme ils s'appellent quand ils
préfèrent s'appelait on conçoit un outil
de mesure qui va être un outil de mesure
pour l'industrie pas juste pour radio
canada parce que nous en étions nous
avez vu tout à l'heure on est capable de
mesurer assez bien ce qu'on fait mais ça
prend un outil pour l'ensemble de
l'industrie est un outil qu'accepte
l'ensemble de l'industrie
donc c'est en train de se développer en
ce moment et il n'y a pas juste radio
canada qui paient pour développer cet
outil là nos coûts nos collègues de tv
up est aussi et les producteurs et les
directeurs de casting cdc
c'est le temps de faire intervenir le
public le grand public dans nos débats
n'est pas ce que nous sur le web via que
ça le grand public n'est ce pas qui
importe
alors voici la question la question tam
tam cette semaine et je demandais à
marie-claude ira voici donc la question
qui apparaîtra dans quelques secondes la
question mystère pour moi
et la voici la voilà les médias autour
de vous web radio télévision refléter
l'importance de la société
multiculturelle qui vous entourent dans
votre pays ou encore la présence des
femmes au quotidien
c'est très long une question
radio-canadienne moi je dirais la
question la pisam c est ce que vous vous
reconnaissez à notre antenne un point
final alors on a une réponse qui nous
vient de loin très très occupé à suivre
les autres médias cette semaine ainsi
qu'une réponse mais elle vient de france
est al omar nous écrit on aime toujours
la lyre à votre tour maintenant de nous
livrer le commentaire dans françoise
depardieu dit oui ici dans le sud de la
france nos médias surtout à la télé
reflète de plus en plus du fidèlement
les visages de ces étrangers qui vivent
maintenant dans nos villes comme
toulouse bordeaux est bien évidemment
marseille les femmes toutes couleurs
confondues sont aussi plus
cible mais je trouve que plus au nord
lille paris et en bretagne
la télévision et plus réfractaires et ne
s'adaptent pas beaucoup les comédiens
étrangers perce mais très peu les
musulmans mon mari me faire remarquer
avec justesse je dois l'avouer qu'avec
nos télévisions plein de couleurs on a
tendance à mettre de côté de plus sain
plus souvent l'homme blanc de 40 essonne
entre 40 et 60 ans il dit contente de
corriger encore en créant un autre
ilhama fois raison moi je trouve qu'il
ya parfois trop défendre paraît que
c'est un peu la télé j'aime bien
regarder un bel homme blanc aux cheveux
grisonnants chose là dedans
la première c'est la place des femmes
comme celle des minorités visé dans
notre antenne
vous êtes un sujet également qui vous
qui vous un qui vous préoccupe la place
des femmes abbas est essentiel parce que
si les femmes n'ont pas fait leur place
à l'antenne ça va être très difficile
pour d'autres groupes sociaux à part des
hommes plan de 40 à 60 ans bien
représentée ici autour de la table c'est
essentiel et autant il ya beaucoup de
femmes à l'antenne dans nos émissions de
variété dans nos séries télévisées
autant c'est plus difficile du côté les
émissions d'information alors parce que
souvent dans ces émissions en interviews
des des gens qui sont responsables en
économie en politique c'est que ces
émissions par beaucoup de terrorisme de
sécurité et plus souvent qu'autrement ce
sont des hommes et souvent à cette
catégorie de 40 métro 70 ans n'ont pas
ce 60 et donc on voit
niemand ce déséquilibre ce à peu près
trois quarts 20 43 cas homme et un quart
femmes donc on a deux des efforts du
travail à faire pour amener davantage de
femmes à notre antenne
voici vidéo numéro je pars c'est la
numéro cinq en espèces et mon dieu sur
cette colline ça bouge aujourd'hui alors
voici numéro 5 c'est ça c'est tiré d'un
article que j'ai moi même écrit passons
au mois d'octobre dernier
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont si visage est-ce
que vous rappeler l'événement médiatique
qui nous a offert ce oui le lancement de
deux nouveaux des nationaux c'est le
téléjournal au soir secib ici donc il
recherchait un remplacement à un homme
blanc de près 61 et qui alors ils ont
dit on va choisir 4 mais qu'est ce qui
manque ici c'est ma question c'est pas
ma question remue méninges mais c'est
quand même un caisson qui manque ici
lambelin ce qu'il faut pas oublier ces
cas là on parle des artisans de des
nouvelles si on veut ce qu'il y présente
ce qu'ils font les recherches mais le
contenu en soi des nouvelles être dominé
par les hommes blancs de toute façon il
faut vraiment mais on peut contrôler sa
façon de voir les choses
je vous pose la question parce que mon
jour 12h41 maintenant je vais vous
demander très très humblement
est ce que nos efforts d'inclusion ne
force pas l'exclusion de certains
c'était ses fans il faut il faut pas se
mettre la tête dans le sable
et puis l'idée je pense de faire de la
place à tout le monde ce n'est pas
d'exclure personne mais c'est d'offrir
un portrait qui soit un peu plus fidèle
à celui de l'eau histoire des
téléspectateurs d une star qu'on cherche
à représenter mais évidemment il ne
s'agira jamais d'exclure une certaine
catégorie au détriment d'une autre
il va y avoir encore des hommes blancs
j'espère vous m'avez invité
au stade où il faut s'inquiéter de la
présence de fichiers de leur jeu mais la
présence des hommes verts pour écouter
question numéro deux questions remis et
vous l'aimez neige aujourd'hui ce trait
c'est moi j'ai choisi des choses simples
soul est sûr que tout le monde ait une
chance d'avoir la bonne réponse au
problème
je regarde pas parce que souvent il a
gagné avec marie-claude aussi été
champion depuis un mois comme ça alors
voici la question numéro deux c'est bon
pour 30% de l'examen final matinale en
2015 et minorités visibles représentait
20% un peu plus de 20% de la population
du montréal métropolitain ce chiffre
qu'on a
quel était le pourcentage des minorités
visibles cependant parmi les chefs
d'entreprise les hauts cadres dans les
entreprises mais je dirais ça j'ai pas
la réponse ici je dirais 4,4 pour ça je
me distingue j 3 3 pour sa 5 5 4 3 5 2
la bonne réponse et 5% qui à 10,5 pour
ça maintenant 50 % de la note alors la
bonne réponse et 5 % des postes de haute
direction occupés par des personnes de
minorités visibles en 2015 dans morjan
la grande région de montréal est cité en
fait moins bons qu'en 2012
hier c'était 7% en 2012
donc le progrès pas toujours de la bonne
direction en espagne et ça ça montre
c'est enfin si vous permettez que ya pas
de mouvements naturels dans question ne
provoque pas des choses si on n'accélère
pas le mouvement
il se produira pas naturellement il faut
prendre des mesures
les quotas ne sont généralement pas la
bonne façon de faire parce que ça fait
porte un poids démesuré sur les épaules
des gens qui serait choisi par quotas
mais il faut d'autres types de mesures
est compris dans la grande entreprise on
voit ça n'a pas de bon sens que ça va
être
mais quand on a commencé à faire les
formations pour les journalistes à la
recherche du ciet radio-canada oui on
leur donne des soucis mélissa faire leur
travail c'est plus une question de
changer deux des paramètres de
fonctionnement parce que parfois on est
habitué à faire notre travail d'une
certaine manière on est habitué de
trouver un invité à l'antenne dans la
dans l'heure qui suit la demande et donc
ce qu'on leur dise et il faut se donner
le temps et prend des risques parce que
invité une nouvelle personne en ondes ce
n'est pas évident donc on va toujours
pour la personne qu'on sait qui va
répondre à nos questions qui va répondre
au téléphone qui va être disponible donc
et puis qui va répondre exactement dans
les mêmes paramètres que des lacets de
la fois passé donc quand on veut éviter
une nouvelle personne qui a pas beaucoup
d'expérience dans les médias mais il
faut prendre le temps de défaire du
travail avec cette personne je passe au
mois de novembre
radio canada international de se
déplacer cette émission s'est déplacé un
forum sur des communautés arabes à
montréal et il ya eu discussion on n'a
pas de sens non mais c'était hors d'onde
il ya un monsieur un journaliste bien
connu dans la communauté rom qui dit il
me disait il va falloir former des
élites parasites mais des gens qui
peuvent prendre leur place aux côtés des
élites dans les médias traditionnels et
ils s'inquiétaient du fait peut-être que
bon il y avait peut-être pas le nombre
suffisant moi je vais peut-être
d'obtenir différents parce que je
trouvais qu'il était déjà pas mal pas
mal pas mal drian cet homme en me disant
que soit le problème c'est que dans les
communautés
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent mais
oui c'est moi oui d'accord mais je veux
pas parce que j'ose pas je n'ai pas fait
pas seulement ils sont émis pense qu'ils
ne sont pas bons mais ils le sont il ya
cette gêne c'est pas notre langue
maternelle souvent souvent le français
est notre deuxième où notre troisième
l'an parfois la quatrième langue que les
personnes parlent donc c'est évidemment
pas facile de se mettre de l'avant
et puis ça arrive aussi avec les femmes
on l'a vu avec l'équipe de ici rdi à rdi
économie par dont on a parlé et elle
fait partie de notre formation là
la pluralité à la recherche louise
brassard puel nous raconter qu'elle
voulait amener des femmes à l'émission
puis que les femmes avaient tendance à
dire oui je suis je connais ce sujet
mais je préfère que mon collègue homme
est à l'émission pas pourquoi parce
qu'il va être plus à l'aise il va être
moins gêné c'est la même chose pour les
allophones même s'ils semblent ils sont
experts dans leur domaine ils vont senti
que quelqu'un dont la langue maternelle
est le français ou l'anglais dans
certains cas va être plus pertinent à
l'antenne plus rap et plus donc c'est
une question d'être des de sécurité mais
immigrés et stéphane c'était difficile
immigrés cette émission si combien de
fois qu'on a on est on a fait un appel
en faisant pas parce qu'il était non
seulement une femme ont sédiments s
est-elle bonne et les spécialistes elle
connaît la chose et on la contacte ne
répond pas et on se dit mais qu'est-ce
que je fais là je vais leur premier
réflexe on va ans est urgent il reste
deux heures on va compléter on va aller
chercher quelqu'un qui narre convoi on
entend tout le temps c'est facile mais
d'abord et f
on veut à trouver la bonne personne mais
parce que ces réticences là on ne sait
pas il ya quelqu'un qui m'a écrit ce
matin disant oh désolé ça 2 - 3 mois
maintenant j'ai pas répondu plus tôt
mais là c'est parce qu'elle avait un
compte facebook sur lesquels elle se
promène pas souvent et j'ai pensé la
contacter la qualité aussi bien des fois
vous savez puis les gens qui nous
écoutent seront tête et au nez il ya
juste trois critères qui explique qu'on
évite une personne plutôt que tel autre
à l'antenne le premier critère c'est
qu'elles soient disponibles
je péterais celui là va si vous
permettez stéphane le deuxième la
compétence monter les inverser et le
troisième c'est qu'il donne une bonne
performance à l'antenne c'est toujours
les mêmes trois critères et les gens qui
que con contact ils ont beau être très
compétent puis faire une bonne
performance mais s'ils sont pas
disponibles pour les entendre au port
oui si ce n' est pas disponible c'est
par crainte sans panique vous avez
aucune difficulté à vous mettre de
l'avant je constate un compliment mais
leonardo vous aviez des choses a ajouté
moi
argentine ce travail espagnol bien sûr
puis je suis très attentif aux détails
ok quand je parle d'un espagnol puis en
français je sais que j'ai des fautes
je sais que je quand je m'exprime c'est
pas très correct vous pouvez dire que
j'ai commis des fautes
alors j'aime pas trop être l là il ya
des passants qui ont appelé pour parler
je me rappelle la tam tam et quand on
faisait les ondes courtes
j'ai participé de trois fois puis
j'avais pas envie de participer
parce que je me sens que je suis pas à
l'aise en parla en français je pense que
peut-être c'est ça une des barrières
exactement parce que je connais leonardo
da pour avoir travaillé aussi en
espagnol
et puis la personnalité et aux annonces
etc
on l'attend parle avec ses cols avec des
fois et gesticuler c'est intéressant
parce que la question des accents c'est
peut-être la principale barrière qui
expliquerait qu'on a des chiffres aussi
bons accords dans nos invités dans les
émissions de radio ou de où les
émissions d'information
c'est ce n'est pas souvent mentionné ce
n'est pas souvent identifiés mais c'est
la cb oui c'est l'accepter mais il ya
des plaintes on est c'est à dire que
c'est à cause de sa non pas deux mais
chapeau sous un de mes chapeaux je
m'occupe de la réponse aux plaintes pour
les émissions d'information et je n'ai
jamais vu à une exception peut-être au
fil des ans quelqu'un se plaint d'un
accent à l'antenne alors si on comprend
des gens peu importe leur accent il n'y
a pas de diapos de problème mais il y à
une hésitation et je dirais que ce n'est
pas propre
d'ailleurs à radio canada ou aux médias
québécois c'est la même chose du côté du
canada anglais cela mais chose à siby
6-2 relativement peu de tolérance aux
accents et puis ben puisqu'on est sur
internet c'est la même chose en france
ça mais chaud dans notre pays
vous êtes prêts pour la question numéro
trois premiers vous l'aimez neige
il a l'air un peu fatigué on est fatigué
départ mais oui 50 pour cent pour coter
déjà engagés comme d'animer la formalité
de rap et 20% dans votre nom parce que
j'ai pas participé à la première
question je n'ai pas pensé
non parce que je connais c'est la
réponse donc que vous voulez avec pour
centre s'il vous plaît la prochaine
question qu'on 51 pour ça ça va bien se
passer des choses mais 50% seulement
alors je pense qu'on se dirige vers une
grande gagnante
on y voit alors je dévale voici célébrer
la diversité dans l'espace médiatique
c'est notre thème aujourd'hui n'est-ce
pas si on se reporte est dans notre
machine à remonter le temps en 2005
voyons comment ça se passe et les choses
une enquête réalisée par le conseil de
l'industrie des communications du québec
révèlent l'importance de la présence ou
là n'ont d'importance des minorités à
l'antenne parmi les professionnels des
journalistes dans une salle d'une
nouvelle quel pourcentage appartenait à
une minorité visible
en 2005 il ya une enquête similaire
fatou canada quand c'est en l'an 2000 et
on arrive aux mêmes chiffres
donc si vous d'où le bond de 3% 3 pour
soit d'accord cinq par cinq pour sa 2 2%
à 4
pourquoi vous suivez pas celui-là parce
qu'il connaît tous c'est son domaine le
journalisme commis alors si la bonne
réponse est un non sens délicate mais si
tous proches que parce que j'avais vu
d'étude en question il ya déjà certains
on voyait que le gaz il s'est préparé il
avait gagné avec stéphane ce serait
intéressant de le refaire cette étude là
à cause de la crise des médias la
fermeture de beaucoup de médias le fait
ce sont les plus anciens qui reste quand
il ya des mises à pied je sais pas ce
que ça serait beaucoup plus élevé
aujourd'hui malheureusement c'est ça
c'est vrai on fait mieux c'est quoi
c'est autour de 10 + 10 %
il faut le réduire comme sur une bonne
note mais pas une note satisfaisante
non encourageant même très bien alors je
sais qu'on avait d'autres choses prévues
au menu dans un reportage que vous avez
effectués je vous donne le titre vous
allez me dire vous n'êtes que voter je
suis je me souviens être allé voir c'est
au sujet de trois quartiers
ah oui oui c'est très beau et ne trouve
très belle entrevue qu'elle ait fait du
sujet oui c'est un projet l'asean musset
on peut passer des images donc vous
parler pendant 30 secondes pas plus
parce est passé lui là bas non c'est pas
celui-là c'est le prochain star fait y'a
pas de problème
vidéo 3 quartiers
donc c'est vous reconnaissez l'image
connaît l'image effectivement un projet
quartier par quartier ce une exposition
virtuelle qui a eu lieu un fait à
toronto à vicky montréal avait quand
même s'envoler
donc ils sont allés rencontrer les gens
de différents quartiers de trois
quartiers et de modems de montréal où
les immigrants et sont les plus
pressants une entrevue avec phyllis l'ol
a bel accent anglophone
donc c'était très intéressant de parler
à phyllis louise à cet art et artiste
visuel qui travaille pour le compte de
monsieur howard à toronto on écoute un
peu avec le son on monte le son est la
diversité culturelle dans les trois
villes
mais ce qui est vraiment intéressant à
toronto et à vancouver dans les deux
quartiers
il s'est presque
il existe presque plus de personnes
maintenant ces quartiers là le plus tard
c'est donc c'est juste les entreprises
et non des 10 elle expliqué élevée par
l'aide à ce moment là quand le seuil à
plus de personnes 7 d'origine immigrante
elle voulait dire parce que ces
quartiers dont on a fait le roman
comment dire d'un ton affaire là
l'exposition sur laquelle s'est passé
c'était cette exposition là c'était le
quartier immigrants à travers le pays
et puis ai raconté comment certains
quartiers d'origine allemand immigrants
considéré étaient devenus des quartiers
industriels et aux tandis qu'à montréal
a continué de décevoir beaucoup de
populations immigrantes alors pour
continuer cette histoire pour toute
l'histoire
le reportage intégral sur la page de
tam-tam canada aujourd'hui comme
d'autres reportages qui sont qui sont
bas qui sont le reflet de notre émission
aujourd'hui je les termine et c'est que
les gens qui prennent le temps nous
écrire c'est du temps qu'il prenne pas
écrire d'autres personnes je pense c'est
très bien de les encourager
alors à la suite de notre émission la
semaine dernière sur le ronflement et
les trucs qui attrapent pour apprendre à
dormir avec son conjoint
la nuit on a eu deux suggestions enfin
2-2 internautes qui nous ont écrit
commentaires de serge la marche on va
demander à luc simard de nous lire ce
commentaire de ce qu'est belloy monsieur
la marche nous y depuis quelques jours
j'ai lu un truc pour s'endormir plus
facilement au lieu de compter les
moutons il faut chercher des mots par
exemple je cherche des mots qui
finissent par eau et je passe tout
l'alphabet aéro bible au cachot d'eau
etc
je m'endors souvent avant m mais c'est
très variable fonds peut compliquer le
jeu mais il ne faut pas s'entêter si on
n'en trouve pas un certaines lettres ont
moins de mots mais sinon on s'endort
plus ça compliqué la vie
linda
ni trucs pour apprendre à dormir avec
les autres de monsieur françois vernon
moi je pense à tout ce que j'aime en
rafale une après l'autre et je leur
souhaite le bonheur la santé la
prospérité à la fin de cette grande
liste je dors et c'est certain et je
ronfle et je me réveille comme toi serge
avec mes propres ronflements c'est un
jeu qui qui urgent c'était le serge les
internautes peuvent lire ce livre c'est
comme ça que le monde fonctionne
aujourd'hui
paloma martinez merci beaucoup merci à
mustapha luc sina à lux in a c'est
qu'elle prononce pas mais cinar c'est le
nom ça n'existe plus mais c'est une
compagnie qui faisaient de cinéma et de
l'animation pour enfants alors luc
simard merci beaucoup merci
et puis marie claude simard à la
prochaine leonardo gibernau gibernau
merci beaucoup pour votre mère
merveilleuse accent
[Rires]